oh excuse me
[Music]
is there a toilet nearby quickly do you
mind i'll go for a pig is it nearby
there's right into the green room right
into the green room
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and it's
a banner day in internet history as we
open up season eight with gordon ramsay
he's one of the world's most decorated
and successful chefs with an empire that
includes more than a dozen restaurants
countless best-selling cookbooks and
seven hit tv shows including masterchef
junior which returns to fox this
february gordon ramsay welcome to the
show great to see you so we started hot
ones about four years ago and shortly
after we put up our first episode we
were bombarded with requests to get
gordon ramsay on the show and as the
show has grown so too has that albatross
around our necks which has followed me
from the internet to the airport to my
family get togethers so this one is very
much for the fans i'm nervous in a good
way but at the same time i feel like a
weight has been lifted off my shoulder
so i just want to say thank you for
coming in today you're welcome good to
see you congrats by the way thank you
very much nate amazing um i have four
kids
they're
paying me to come on this dad i want to
see how good your palate is or how
strong your palate is you got a big
mouth
you shout and scream all day long but
can you take a hot wing so finally under
immense pressure from the family and a
lot of supporters out there i'm here the
world has pressured us into this room
gordon that is it if it all goes tits up
after this it doesn't matter we made the
hot ones okay
[Music]
okay so how long would these wings cook
for
uh oh i knew that this was gonna happen
yeah
yeah because a bit [ __ ] overcooked
it's like eating a mouthful of [ __ ]
sand
[Music]
a good wing look at your arms
that's a good wing right there yeah but
so it needs a bit meat on there it's
[ __ ] things like a quail
so gordon as we mentioned in your intro
masterchef junior comes back next month
one of your many shows that become a
global phenomenon when you think back in
all the times you've been wowed by the
raw talent of a child on that show is
there a story that stands out
um i think of some of the uh earlier
kids now um you know back on season one
yeah they're into the 18 19 year old um
alexander from season one and you know
this guy is a prolific chef he's barely
19 years of age and for the last five
years he spent weekends and holidays in
some of the most amazing restaurants
across the world so i say to them no mom
no dad no school teacher you love me
you're gonna hate me it's gonna be the
best football coach you've ever met in
your life but you'll come out of this a
much better cook and they do what's been
the most disturbing thing that you've
ever seen unnoticed or uncared for at a
restaurant on kitchen nightmares
that's a really good question so um i
went into a refrigeration unit once and
saw a tatar sauce
three and a half years out of date
how [ __ ] dumb must you be to use this
tatar sauce that stank
to use a sauce that's festering bubbling
like something out [ __ ] harry potter
that was off three years ago um several
stuart littles spotted in the corner of
the kitchen
yeah big [ __ ] not like cats
i didn't know they only had cats they
didn't it wasn't it was a [ __ ] rats
yeah pretty shocking uh from rats to
mold
uh to recently um
coming across the restaurant with
plastic cheese over nachos covered in
mold do you have any idea how long
cheese needs to sit in a fridge that's
plastic cheese to get mold
[ __ ] years
yes
hippie dippy green what are they smoking
when they come up with these names
probably opium
okay so the restaurant business is
notoriously difficult with these thin
margins and then of course infinite
space for human error and then when
you're a chef who's famous and has this
large empire that goes across several
continents you end up being a target for
the type of yelper or trip advisor
commenter that's like this place is a
total ripoff i could have made it for
three dollars can you explain in
layman's terms the basic math behind how
a 25 cheeseburger might end up on a menu
i've seen
chefs with
freaking gold leaf on a burger right to
get to 100 mark which is a bit stupid
really because you don't go need a
[ __ ] burger with gold leaf
and why taint that flavor so
uh 25 burger it's all about the patty
the thickness the blend it depends on
whether it's the chuck the short rib a
great brioche bun
and how you lay that up with you know
all the trappings of a luxurious burger
is there a hidden cost in running a
restaurant that most diners are unaware
of yeah it's called rent and labor cost
two big key factors in running a
successful business um
landlords uh
they win either way so the more
successful you are the more rent they
ask for uh the less successful you are
uh the more demanding they are for the
rent so the great way of identifying a
classy restaurant is being full on a
monday night friday saturday will look
that will take care of itself naturally
if you can fill it monday tuesday
wednesday you're 90 of the way there
[Music]
[ __ ] grapefruit in a hot sauce
are you serious i know that you spent
your early years studying classic french
technique and bouncing around
restaurants and london and paris working
alongside some of the most influential
chefs in the world so with that in mind
i want to bounce some of the people some
of the mentors that helped shape gordon
ramsay into this battle-hardened
perfectionist that we see today i'm just
curious what you learned about cooking
what you learned about business maybe
even what you learned about life from
each okay we'll start with marco pierre
white
a [ __ ] phenomenon
a nut buster uh ball breaker super
talented chef if you thought my
performance sometimes was shocking in
the kitchen that was a [ __ ] hollywood
blockbuster right there oscar-nominated
marketplace um
that guy had finesse he could close his
eyes and dress a plate beautifully uh
and he could come out looking like a
gucci handbag i mean stunning how about
gizaboi
kisawa was amazing it's like this
perfect frenchman that was you know hard
as [ __ ] on the outside
and then you look at him it's the kind
of guy that your grandma would take to
the [ __ ] bingo we had one and a half
days off a week that half a day if you
took that half day you're [ __ ] so you
had to be in there no pay
and showing willingness you know to
learn and as an english cook in a french
kitchen i had to bust my ass off twice
as hard now you know one of the best
chefs living today
and still a prominent figure in odd
cuisine how about joelle rubicon robert
shawn was a task master combined
marco tony bourdain
all together and you've got joe robichon
because you know
on the outside world there's this
incredible successful genius but behind
the scenes oh my god you know from
raviolis flying over your head to
[ __ ] copper pans to i used to see
ducks flying uh from one of the kits to
the other thinking that just reborn
their [ __ ] wings the only thing was
missing were the feathers i remember
telling me that the best thing ever
happened to me was the [ __ ] that ran
down my mother's leg when she gave birth
to me how did you get up in the morning
and concentrate at work the next day on
that one then so for all those beautiful
millennials and snowflakes out there
trust me
the more you get pushed the thicker your
skin the thicker your skin trust me the
higher you go
[Music]
cheaper gold from where yeah the new
jersey right chiva gold
um do you mind if i sponsor the wings
going forward and like pay for some
[ __ ] decent meat on the bones
that would be a dream come true for us
trade emails we'll trade emails
so that's nippy at the beginning it's
like nip
immediately so it's not um
yeah it's fine though mm-hmm it's not
it's not super hot
so with your many best-selling cookbooks
then your how-to tutorials online you've
inspired a generation maybe several how
to up their food game but today we want
to give a lesson to the spice lords can
you break down the perfect gordon ramsay
at home burger and describe how to make
it in as much detail as possible yeah um
so
for me it's about that blend
i would go uh 60 grand beef
10 fat
blend that with 10 chuck
and then i would do
almost like a luxurious four rib in
there and then the last part somewhat
lean so a bit of a try tri-tip in there
in a way that it sort of holds that
thing together so it's tight
the cigarette are a great burger is in
the seasoning
and so too many people make the burger
but they don't season it properly so
season this thing
chili flakes garlic powder salt pepper
severe sear strong caramelization on top
and then it's the basting and so once
you've caramelized that burger on top
don't worry about it still being raw
inside you baste because as you base
that butter it seeps through and becomes
so much more richer the fat caramelizes
on top of the burger so the flavor layer
is beautiful brioche bun beautifully
toasted and then baked so not is it
toasted but it holds substantially all
those juices
the most important thing about a burger
let that thing rest before you bite into
it
and that's what happens sometimes they
cook the burger they bite in the meal
it's oh man it's all pissing out yeah
let it rest let it sit inside there
and then stack it usually
[Music]
so you made this one and uh is that a
[ __ ] day 2017. can you afford [ __ ]
sauce in dates uh-oh you know what these
are just stage battles oh they're still
good yeah [ __ ]
here we go so
um
oh it's quite nice i like that you do
yeah it's quite zesty that's that's
fruity i like that smoked serranos some
orange in there
yeah i mean i'm not too sure about
apricot but
that's nice big
big
that's good thank you so much now it's
getting hotter yep yeah a little bit is
sort of um
yeah it's starting to move on the
armpits i'm sweating that's how we do it
here gordon all right gordon we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that graham we're doing deep
dive and i guess instagram pulled
interesting pictures that need more
context yes i'll bust out the laptop
i'll show you the picture sure you just
tell me the bigger story does that sound
good yes sir
how are you doing so far brilliantly
dive on people's [ __ ] instagram
what's wrong with you girlfriend
okay gordon first things first do you
remember this meeting of the minds
courtside at the lakers game you david
beckham and kobe bryant
i got absolutely [ __ ] there
really yeah because five minutes prior
to that i threw the first ball out of
the dodger stadium
the game was so [ __ ] boring db takes
me so fancy basketball so i went to the
basketball i got into such trouble
because you can't go from throwing the
first pitch out then going watching the
[ __ ] basketball ten minutes later can
you
well you can apparently no not good um
so um yeah sat ringside there
it was the first time in my life at six
foot two i felt like a short ass
everyone's [ __ ] seven foot tall it's
no longer down there it's like [ __ ]
so uh loved the game um and uh yeah kobe
one athlete jesus uh incredible do you
remember this lunch service at downing
street with tony blair and vladimir
putin
yeah i mean quite honestly probably the
first time as a chef i stood between two
guys customers actually shot myself
thinking this could go off any minute
entering down the street uh getting
pelted by
see there was supporters outside there
antique putin and anti-vlan
ever since that day i've never got
involved in politics right based on that
lunch
can you imagine turning one of those
leaders ill based on a [ __ ] bad
oyster or a [ __ ] chicken wing we didn't
serve chicken wings there by the way i
did the most i did the most amazing pan
roasted sea bass with a coffee tomato
and a beautiful shellfish vinaigrette
and we finished with a bakewa tart so i
remember the menu you know as if it was
last week powerful lunch but couldn't
wait to get the [ __ ] out of there
[Music]
yeah okay that's hot now i'm tingling
everywhere yeah in the back half here
okay
so we've talked a lot about your
tangible accomplishments yes michelin
stars tv ratings but i'm curious about
some of the more unusual highlights and
low lights from your life okay of the
following daredevil moments which was
more intense hunting down a burmese
python butchering a wild boar or
tracking down puffins in iceland
um yeah i'd have to say tracking down
puffins in iceland i mean don't forget
this is how this country lived you know
for for for for decades that level of
protein across those winter months is
brutal so um
sort of
hanging off a 600 meter high cliff uh
with a rope and a [ __ ] net catching
this furry bird
to eat um
i made this amazing uh dish [ __ ] that's
hot that thing by the way [ __ ] it's
starting to come through now what are
you laughing at
[ __ ]
yeah you'll take a big deep breath so um
i made this amazing uh puffin
salad
made this bread um
[Music]
and and proved it in this uh
active volcano in iceland
dug the hole stuck it in amongst these
rocks
came back the next day and [ __ ] bread
was nicked someone stole it
so i'm still looking for that viking
that stole that [ __ ] amazing loaf of
bread bastards
[Music]
yeah that's moving yeah yeah also it's
just a little bit
it's not um
not good that one is it it's a tough one
yes what's the one also it's us
so when people have reached their peak
in a profession whether it's kobe bryant
i think that's uh
i feel like that's burning a new ring on
my [ __ ] ass
you and i both gordon i die on this one
now i know what that listening song
means ring of fire was that johnny cash
i was one of this [ __ ] seat there's
nothing coming through so we're okay all
right but everybody in production be
ready okay
yeah ring of fire holy [ __ ] yeah that's
hot is somebody with a foot in both
worlds who's more insufferable tv
critics or restaurant critics
they're both cut from the same cloth
because they're both standing staring
they wish they could be you so [ __ ] it
take on the chin
two pieces in the same pod well you know
it seems like on paper at least that you
would enjoy the linguistic flair of a
good takedown so i'm curious i want to
hit you with a few infamously savage
restaurant reviews and i'm just curious
how about you hit your ear
from an insult level before you go there
i remember once uh the evening standard
years ago when i first opened and this
amazing food critic described one of my
dishes
yeah [ __ ] yeah looking like toxic scum
on a stagnant pool i'm like [ __ ]
really that's how you describe my
[ __ ] dish toxic skull on a stagnant
pool [ __ ]
did i really hurt you that much
let me bounce this one off of you it's
from jay raynor writing for the guardian
in 2013 he said of the muscles at lyonde
brussels in london the meat inside the
shells is small and shriveled and dry
each shell contains what looks like the
retracted scrotum of a hairless cat wow
so that's savage right yeah so we can't
talk about critics like that but they
can talk about us like that i'm a firm
believer in keeping it professional but
not personal so i had to run in once
with a critic and unfortunately i asked
him to leave
uh but [ __ ] my heart's beating as well
like [ __ ] the drum what's going on
with these [ __ ] wings did you make
this sauce this next one is from pete
wells in the new york times guy fieri's
restaurant in times square why is one of
the few things on your menu that can be
eaten without fear regret called a
roasted pork bon me when it resembles
that item about as much as you resemble
emily dickinson jesus christ almighty
good morning glad you've had a [ __ ]
great day
uh i know guy um but any chef that turns
around puts donkey sauce on his [ __ ]
menu you're gonna get a kick in okay
because if my wife was sat there
thinking sweetheart i'm gonna have the
ribs with the donkey sauce
it doesn't quite ring well does it
you know [ __ ] happens take it okay and
shut the [ __ ] up and then one more at
the risk of being a bit cheeky this one
is from the late sunday times writer a.a
gil about your own restaurant aubergine
in the 90s the chef is a failed
sportsman who acts like an 11 year old
[ __ ] him
[Laughter]
[ __ ] him
yeah i didn't realize coming to the hot
ones i'd leave with [ __ ] three
[ __ ]
yeah i mean jesus christ it's nice to
have a [ __ ] nuclear lap look at the
label on that [ __ ] thing jeremy huh
that haunts my dreams yeah i mean the
wings are getting [ __ ] small and
smaller now they look like my [ __ ]
granddad's no [ __ ] these [ __ ] big
toe how do you get a chicken wing that
looks like my granddad's big toe wait
till you bite into it
tastes like your grandfather's big toe
oh yeah
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] yeah
that's like [ __ ] sticking your tongue
in a [ __ ] plate of acid
jesus christ yes what's the [ __ ] gonna
happen tomorrow when i'm back behind the
line tasting and perfecting where the
[ __ ] are you gonna be tomorrow because i
mean not to call you
[ __ ] i'll be in town i'll be in town
gordon
and you're never one to mince words when
it comes to items that don't reach your
culinary standards whether it's your pub
food that's laced in truffle oil or
tasting menus overrun with foams but how
does gordon ramsay feel about some of
the 2018 food trends that have been
bubbling up across social media
we'll find out today steven
laptop please
gordon
how you doing my
man now i feel like i've just swallowed
a [ __ ] mouth full of bandages
do you have any thoughts on this black
foods trend known as goth foods
everything from jet black ice cream to
all black burger buns made with
activated charcoal
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] out really
[ __ ] i'm now [ __ ] crying over a
[ __ ] wing
and man that's [ __ ] hot yeah
so charcoal foods
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that's hot uh-huh
how am i gonna go to the toilet later
you know it's an adventure for everyone
careful on the eyes
so
do i really want to take my daughters
for an ice cream and eat [ __ ]
charcoal with vinegar not really no
so these guys developing this [ __ ] got
too much [ __ ] time on their hands
do you have any thoughts
on this which is a spaghetti donut
how [ __ ] stupid really a spaghetti
donut get [ __ ] real with you well if
you think that's stupid do you have any
thoughts on this
which is a sushi croissant
and then we also have sushi
donuts you know so i love japanese food
and to have a [ __ ] sushi donut
what the [ __ ] are these guys smoking did
that come out of portland
do you think that chefs have any
obligation to respect the origins of
food or is it all fair game no
culturally yeah
they need to go on this is amazing
the lime does that work
[Music]
[ __ ]
and then one more for you
have you heard of avo lattes
lattes
inside of an avocado is that the
snowflake generation again a latte in an
avocado that's [ __ ] stupid i mean
really what is wrong with these people
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
are you out of things in the back now
i've got more coming trust me
do we really have two more to go
just two more to go
[ __ ] how they're almost there
thank you i haven't tried this much
since [ __ ] ia's gail's funeral
[ __ ] how
[Music]
[ __ ]
so if i you know literally take
something sweet
i love that you came this prepared thank
you very much gordon very sweet of you
so that's sweetness from the [ __ ]
donut i [ __ ] hate donuts but because
i don't want to look like a fat [ __ ] so
i um i'm counting out the heat with some
sweetness
but we're sweating off the calories too
at the same time you know that donut
does help a little bit it does we like
small yes please
[ __ ] it out
[ __ ]
[ __ ] it
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
that's not normal no in fact this
[ __ ] program is not normal have you
ever killed anybody
we haven't heard from coolio in a long
time
[ __ ] hell seriously
[ __ ] waiting for us
excuse me [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ]
someone knows hell's kitchen and master
chef but for my money some of your most
interesting programming happens outside
of the restaurant setting
like when you went to brixton prison to
teach inmates how to cook of course your
itv documentary about drug abuse in the
restaurant industry
what was your most harrowing experience
while investigating illicit shark fin
trades in costa rica
so
oh [ __ ] me
[ __ ]
um
howard experience um
[ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] two sex
[ __ ]
have some tissues please my [ __ ] nose
is running like [ __ ] mo farah yup
stitches on deck
[ __ ] you know
damn coming through
thank you sir james
[Music]
[ __ ] it out
[Music]
oh man even my [ __ ] nozzles are hot
every hole in my body is [ __ ]
stinking right now it is ringing like
[ __ ]
most heroin experience for me would be
um
sat underneath those two and a half
meter [ __ ] bull sharks in costa rica
thinking [ __ ] if i get eaten now
i'll never be able to drive my ferrari
again
sharpening
deplorable the decimation across the
ocean is extraordinary we need that for
the ecosystem so
[ __ ] i can't even talk what you've
what the [ __ ] have you done to me
[ __ ] he said come and take some [ __ ]
wings yeah my [ __ ] really
[ __ ] me
[ __ ]
all right gordon here we are at the
finish line this is the last dab we call
it the last app because it's tradition
around here to put a little extra
on the last wing you don't have to if
you don't want to
you don't have to if you don't want to
[Music]
well here you are
proving the kids wrong
they didn't they didn't think you could
do it but here you are
[ __ ] at the iron man finish line of
chicken wings [ __ ]
[ __ ]
ready i'm ready
hit me with a hit me with one
okay
[ __ ]
it's going down
[Music]
all right gordon ramsay here we are
episode eight
season eight episode one almost in the
books and just one more challenge
to go
and this one
is gonna be on me you know you're such a
great teacher such a drill sergeant in
the kitchen and you just sit back and
relax because on this on this wing what
i want to do is make you perfect
scrambled eggs i just need you to coach
me on through it
somebody roll out the mise applause
here it comes
here it comes
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
oh excuse me
is there a toilet nearby quickly do you
mind i've gotta go for a pit is it
nearby it is right into the green room
right into the green room
let's go pan on the stove
let's go
eggs tap
in let's go follow me
tap yeah and then in yeah again
good tap and then in so no season at the
end we never see the beginning right
spatula spatula yes let's start stirring
okay yeah put some energy into it let's
throw this don't stand there and [ __ ]
stare at it stir stir stir okay in break
it up make sure you clean the bottom of
the pan wipe around all the way around
we've got to put some energy into it
sure stir one more
yeah there we go we never salt it first
we salt it now it will actually break
down the egg and turn it watery okay
try keeping the pan as well he's pistol
down the side as well yes have a little
nervous oh stop it come on jesus christ
from there i'll slice up the butter okay
we don't put the uh seasoning in to the
very end
no seasoning yet we put in
a small
lucky now a small knob at a time now we
come off the heat
back around back on there now see you've
got to get down around all those
therefore it's pissing yeah i know it's
not only that i've just gone for a piss
and now i just touched my thing and now
i'm playing oh why my legs are bending
over like that now why don't you tell me
just with some gloves you should give me
some marigolds damn that's on you is
that the chives
what the [ __ ]
is that the [ __ ] you smoke here in
california are you sure they're chives
maybe oh my lord okay
oh [ __ ] oh jesus christ okay
from there
back off the heat again
good
look at this chunking together
good now it's coming together now that's
the texture we won right yes okay
back on and now we start seasoning okay
what [ __ ] end does this thing come
out where'd you get these things from
there we go
all right
go
yeah back off the heat
good
now to slow it down and stop the cooking
process i touch your creme fresh in
there mix that in
yep
so a couple of spoons please [ __ ] my
groin's [ __ ] piping hot now as well
jesus christ the mighty and then from
there finally
in
pull that in now don't beat them
thing where they
taste first because we don't take it out
until you're happy with it
[Music]
what does that need
come on some hot sauce no [ __ ] salt
[ __ ] donut [ __ ] it now we don't put
more [ __ ] hot sauce in there jesus
christ i'll be [ __ ] pissing it in a
minute okay
there textured beautifully done
[Music]
all right
don't you dare put hot sauce on that
it is too perfect the way it is and
thank you very much gordon ramsay
all the way through the hot ones
gauntlet and looking
like a million bucks [ __ ] you
and now there's nothing left to do but
roll out the red carpet for you my
friend this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life oh [ __ ] off right
now i need to see a [ __ ] doctor [ __ ]
yourself
oh my god i've eaten some [ __ ] in my
time
[ __ ] breast milk macaroni and cheese
this has to be the worst i've ever
[ __ ] eaten shame on you big boy
hey what's going on spice lords this is
shawn evans checking in to say thank you
for watching today's episode i pledge
that i will put up a new hot ones next
thursday at 11 a.m and all i ask in
return is that you smash that subscribe
button it's been a childhood dream of
mine long before youtube was invented to
one day have a 5 million subscriber
channel and we're pushing it we're
getting close help make this fully grown
adult man's dream come true
who appreciates you spice lords
i do